griffin canning's on the mound for the
angels this will be his fourth start
two quick outs for griffin matt olson
the first baseman up wind up by counting
and the 2-0 pitch to olson is swung on
and driven
right field way back in no doubt and the
a's take a one-nothing lead
matt olson drills one up into the seats
in right field
at the big a and it's one nothing is in
the first and that's his sixth home run
you know that with so far it kind of
reminds me of what
tim salmon said when barry bonds hit a
home run you could read his lips and
i've never seen a ball hit that far
and for chris bass at his fourth start
last one as we mentioned very good
against the asteroids went seven innings
in his
first start against the angels that was
his first start with just four innings
66
pitches left having really not given up
anything so listel is out that'll bring
up trout is batting at 3 22.
5 for 12 lifetime against bassett 2-2
chow drives one out toward right field
long run for stephen piscotti still
going back and that is gone
big fly for mike trout as he goes oppo
we're tied at one
eighth home run 15 rbis for mike trout
speaking of breaking news he's pretty
good trout continues to crush
the lower part of the strike zone and
he's hit quite a few fast balls out
robbie grossman batting at 3-10 he's
after a great start and he's red-hot
here's the 1-1 pitch to robbie grossman
and robbie it's a drive
deep right center field that's got a
chance to go and it will and grossman
has homered
and the a's take a three to one lead
home run derby at the big a so far today
and grossman
with a two run shot and three to one a's
in the top of the second
griffin kenny made another mistake on a
fastball up in the zone
and instead of rolling over and getting
the ground ball
he takes him deep and there it is
2-2 breaking ball that's roped into left
center that's down for a base hit
rolling toward the track he gets on the
track and up against the wall and
chapman
motors around first he's into second
with another double
his fourth of the year the a's second
today they try to keep it going here to
add on to their 3-1 lead in the third
and now canada trying to drive him in he
doubled the left center it's a full
count on canna
3-1 is the score oakland on top here in
the third
and the next pitch a swing and a miss he
got him he came in with a fastball threw
it by him
struck him out and the inning is over
field back at
double play depth with one out fletcher
again takes off la stella pulls one
through the right side of base hit
goodwin scores fletcher's on his way to
third rbi single for tommy it's 3-2
oakland
a lot of trust in knowing the strike
cell for le stella by joe madden
sending fletch on the move because of a
strikeout throw out you leave trout
in the on deck circle similar situation
now for trout first and third angels is
down by one first pitch the trout he
swings and
pops it up right field carries deep
enough to piscotty
getting in position he makes the catch
tagging from third is fletcher
here comes the throw it's going to be
cut off by olson and we have a tie game
of three
stephen is over one today he swings at a
breaking ball and hits it a long way to
left
goodwin takes one step and it will go
out
man he clocked that ball against griffin
canning
his second home run of the year and the
a's are back in front 4-3
look at the location those balls should
be crushed and i'm glad to see
the a's taking advantage of mistakes by
mckenna as lauriana struck out now olson
flies to left two way that'll bring up
chapman matt's bounced out and doubled
too old pitch now and matt drills one to
left good one back deep in the alley
he'll turn
and watch it hit off the wall it's in
play and scoring from second is simeon
chapman goes to second with a double
and the a's take a 5-3 lead he almost
got it out
and chapman stays red-hot with an rbi
double high off the wall and left center
and these lead 5-3 in the fifth joe
adele will be the first batter up for
the angels as we begin play here in the
bottom of the fifth oakland has a 5-3
lead
slow breaking ball flips this one out to
shallow center fielder ramon loriano
coming on and
slides backhand and makes the catch
nice play by ramon loriano had a long
way to go robs adele of his first extra
base hit
and with the long swing for joe dell
look initially like he didn't get a good
read off the bat but then that speed he
has the aggressive speed slides in and
makes a
great play before he hits the outfield
grass anthony rodono for two
ground down the fly ball to right that's
out towards center field
lorianno racing back he's not going to
get this one big fly
for anthony rendon solo shot his fourth
of the year and the angels are down one
cutter upstairs and crushed the center
for rendon who is red-hot there's
quickly two away for brian goodwin
3-2 swing and a pop-up to center he's
going to carry
back on it as laureano checks the wall
jumps at the wall and he brought it back
loriano saves it yet again
it seemed off the bat that goodwin
didn't get it that well but today
the ball with the crazy carry ramone
stays with it
scales the wall and steals the home run
from goodwin third walk at the end
executed by middleton they're loaded up
and the fish by buntry is a breaking
ball low and the a's take a 6-4 lead how
about that
leading 6-4 bases loaded loriano is up
and he swings and hits it to center
field trout racing toward left center
has to play it on a hop
one run is in and two runs are going to
score loriana with a huge hit in the
eighth inning
and the a's get a cushion as they take
an 8-4 lead
first and third still two outs
olson skies one high and deep to right
field toward the corner of dell
onto the track here the wall leaps up
and he got it
makes the catch for out number three and
olson almost got an extra base hit if
not a home run
two out spot over the ninth is on top of
the angels eight
ready liam throws here it is swung on
and missed on a high fastball up and in
and hendricks
closes out the ball game as the
athletics get a pretty big win here